Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History. We're on day four of our great marathon, the 12 days of Christmas, or indeed in our case, the 13 days of Christmas. Tom Holland's brilliant idea to force me to do nothing. To ruin the week before Christmas. Yeah, by recording endless podcasts about exciting moments
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想收听每周独家加更节目、享受无广告收听、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。今天是我们的伟大马拉松——圣诞12日（或者对我们而言是圣诞13日）的第四天。这是汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）出的绝妙主意，逼得我无事可做，毁掉了圣诞节前的一周。是的，通过录制无数关于多年前的节日里，在这个吉日发生的激动人心时刻的播客。所以，汤姆，你有没有准备一个轻松愉快、充满节日气氛的……我有。这是最轻松愉快、充满节日气氛的。这就是“屠杀无辜婴儿事件”（The Massacre of the Innocents）。好吧。给我们讲讲这个吧。嗯，这可能根本没发生过。好吧，这倒是个好开始。
that happened on this day over the festive season many years ago. So, Tom, do you have a jolly, light-hearted... I do. It's the jolliest and the most light-hearted. It's the Massacre of the Innocents. Right. So tell us about this. Well, it probably didn't happen. OK, that's a good start.
而且如果它真的发生了，那大概也不是在今天发生的。不过今天是个“幼童洗礼日”（Childermass），是教会纪念伯利恒无辜婴儿遭到屠杀的日子。是的。他们被希律王（King Herod）残害，这个故事只在《圣经·马太福音》中被提及：三位智者从东方来到耶路撒冷，他们对希律王说，我们看到了一颗星，犹太人的王诞生了，我们想去向他致敬。希律王对此感到有些紧张，但掩饰了过去，说道：“那你们需要去伯利恒，然后，当你们找到这位犹太人的王是谁时，能回来告诉我吗？因为我也想去，我也想去向他致敬。”
And if it did happen, it probably didn't happen on this day um but today is uh childermass um when the church commemorates the massacre of the innocent babies of bethlehem yeah who were slaughtered by king herod and the story is uh it's only told in the gospel of saint matthew that the three wise men come from the east they come to herod they say we've seen a star um king of the jews has been born we want to go and pay our respects herod is kind of stressed out about this but disguises it um says well you need to go to bethlehem then uh but and when you've discovered who this king of the jews is could you come back and tell me? Because I'd like to. I'd like to go and pay my respects as well.
三位智者前往伯利恒。他们找到了耶稣，向他献上了黄金、乳香和没药。然后，他们受到一位天使的拜访，天使说：“别去告诉希律王。”是的。于是他们回了家。天使也向约瑟显灵，说：“快跑，离开这里。”于是约瑟、马利亚和婴儿耶稣便动身前往埃及。
The three wise men go to Bethlehem. They discover Jesus. They give him the gold, frankincense and myrrh. And then they're visited by an angel who says, don't go and tell Herod. Yeah. So they go back home. Angel also appears to Joseph and says, scram, get out of here. And so Joseph and Mary and the baby Jesus head off to Egypt.
希律王大怒，下令手下屠杀耶路撒冷所有刚出生的男婴。随之而来的便是一场大屠杀。这太疯狂了，因为他明明知道那个婴儿来自伯利恒。他为什么会……嗯，这里有很多问题。是的。首先，一个明显的困惑源头是，传统上与三位智者抵达伯利恒相联系的日子是“主显节”（Epiphany），
Herod is so furious that he orders his men to slaughter all the newborn male babies in Jerusalem. And the carnage ensues. Now, that's mad because he knows that the baby is from Bethlehem. Why would he? Well, there's a lot of questions. Yeah. To begin with, one obvious source of confusion, the day that is traditionally associated with the arrival of the three wise men in Bethlehem is Epiphany,
也就是1月6日。所以……所以希律王在甚至还没……就已经完成了大屠杀。是的，所以这里面有些混乱。是的。
which is the 6th of January. So. So Herod's done the slaughtering before he's even. Yeah. So there's, there's, there's some confusion there. Yeah.
嗯，而且除此之外，没有其他人——你知道的，如果这事真的发生了，没有其他人提及它。因此，其他三位福音书的作者都没有提到；
Um, but also nobody else, you know, if this happened, nobody else mentions it. So none of the other three gospel writers, uh, none.
约瑟夫斯（Josephus）写了大量关于希律王的事情，他是公元一世纪的犹太历史学家，但他也没有提及此事。所以，这件事具有历史真实性的可能性微乎其微。你可能会纳闷，这个故事到底起源于哪里？到底是怎么回事？好吧，我认为这里面有两件事。第一，你可能还记得我们在穆罕默德那一集里谈到过，历史上那些传统上与穆罕默德生平相关的事件，在很大程度上是缺乏历史根据的，其中相当一部分……
So Josephus, who writes an awful lot about Herod, um, Jewish historian of the first century a.d he doesn't mention it either so um the likelihood that this is historical is fairly minimal and so you may wonder well you know what where does the story originate what's going on well okay so i think two things are going on here the first is i mean you may remember in the episode we did on muhammad we talked about um how historically implausible quite a lot of the events that are traditionally associated with the life of muhammad are uh and quite a lot of of um those you know the historical
这些历史荒谬性，但它们并非神学上的荒谬。因此，这里编写的是一种“神圣历史”，它不一定服从那些考A水平（A-level）的学生所理解的历史准则。穆罕默德生平的很多细节都是以摩西的生平为蓝本塑造的。我认为这里发生的也是同一回事，因为在这个故事中，耶稣去了埃及，而摩西则率领以色列人出埃及，那场决定性的灾难——你知道的，法老拒绝让以色列人离开，他遭到了十灾的打击，决定性的灾难就是长子之死。哦，所以这非常相似，对吧？基本上……所以这里有一种回响。我的意思是，这简直是《出埃及记》中发生的事情的镜像。这可以说是确立了耶稣与摩西之间的联系。
implausibilities but they're not theological implausibilities so there's a there's a kind of sacred history that gets written that doesn't necessarily obey the dictates of history as someone doing their A-level, say, might understand it. And an awful lot about the life of Mohammed is modeled on the life of Moses. And I think the same thing is happening here because Jesus is going to Egypt in this case but moses leads the children of israel out of egypt and the climactic plague uh you know pharaoh uh resists allowing the children of israel to leave he gets hit by 10 plagues the climactic plague is the death of the firstborn oh so that's very similar isn't it basically so there's there's the the they of echo. I mean, it's literally kind of mirror image of of what happens in Exodus with this. It's kind of establishing the link between Jesus and Moses.
这种观点认为，基督徒所谓的“旧约”中发生的事情，如今正在“新约”中得到某种回响。希律王在这里扮演的角色是什么呢？嗯，希律王最臭名昭著的事迹就是他杀害了自己的亲生骨肉。他有很多妻子，疑心极重。因此，希律王如果得知出现了一个潜在的、威胁他王位的犹太人国王，他绝对会感到不快，这完全符合他的性格。他甚至会毫不犹豫地杀掉自己的亲生孩子，只要他觉得对方构成了王朝威胁。以至于据说奥古斯都皇帝（Emperor Augustus）开了一个非常滑稽的玩笑，说他宁愿做希律王的猪，也不愿做他的孩子。对吧。
It's this idea that what happened in what Christians call the Old Testament is now being kind of echoed in the New Testament. What is what is the role that Herod is playing in this? Well, the thing that Herod is notorious for is that he kills his own children. So he has a large number of wives. He's very, very suspicious. So that idea that Herod would not be happy to learn that there was a rival potential king of the Jews is absolutely true to his character. He, you know, he's very happy to kill his own children if he feels that they're a dynastic threat. So much so that the Emperor Augustus, it is said, made the very amusing quip that he would rather be, he'd rather be Herod's pig than his child. Right.
你知道，这是一个好笑的笑话。好吧，这个笑话被记录了下来。它是被马克罗比乌斯（Macrobius）记录下来的。他写作的时间要晚得多，大约在第四、第五世纪，但这是一个好笑的笑话。因此我认为这就是当时的背景。等等。
You know, which is a good joke. Okay. Uh, it's, it's, I think it's recorded. It's by recorded by Macrobius. He's writing much later kind of fourth,
马太福音……我们可能会在这里陷入一个巨大的知识迷宫，但它是真的由一个叫马太的人写的吗？首先，大概不是。不。
fifth century, but, um, it's a good joke. Uh, and so I think that that is, that's kind of what's happening there. So hold on.
好吧。那是谁写的？我想我们应该专门做一集来探讨这个。好吧。耶稣与福音书。我的意思是，这真是令人难以置信……你可以想象。不过，他们为什么偏偏跟希律王过不去呢？因为希律王是……好吧，我们别叫它犹太历史记忆了，我们叫它犹太（Judean）历史记忆。
What the gospel of Matthew, um, we could go down a massive rabbit hole here, but is it written? Is it genuinely written by somebody called Matthew? First of all, probably not. No.
马太是在犹太起义的背景下撰写他的福音书的，我们将在新年里专门做一集来讲述这件事。当然，这次起义见证了由希律王建造的圣殿的毁灭，见证了由希律王建造的马萨达（Masada）的攻陷。它见证了由希律王建造的马萨达的攻陷。它见证了犹太起义在凯撒利亚（Caesarea）这个由希律王建造的大港口城市爆发。基本上，一切都是希律王建造的。他是个热衷于宏大工程（Grand Projet）的大人物。而在犹太起义中爆发的种种问题，很大一部分都可以追溯到希律王这个人。希律王曾被描述为少数几个同时遭到犹太人和基督徒痛恨的历史人物之一。但是，希律王本人最初并不是犹太人，对吧？
Okay. So who's writing it? I think we should do an episode on this. Okay. Jesus and the gospels. I mean, it's, it's an incredible,
他是纳巴泰阿拉伯人，对吗？嗯，他自称是犹太人。他皈依了犹太教，对吧？他并非出身于犹太家族。但是，犹太人的身份认同在当时要流动得多、复杂得多。他皈依了犹太教，对吧？他并非出身于犹太家族。但是，犹太人的身份认同在当时要流动得多，比后来的情况要复杂得多。所以他是一个有些矛盾的人物。显然，福音书的作者将他作为基督的对立面来衬托，基督绝不会以传统意义上的国王身份出现，而是会走向十字架。
you can imagine. I mean, but why would they have it in for Herod particularly? Because Herod is the, is the dominant figure in. Well, let's, let's not call it Jewish. Let's call it judean historical memory
这便是两者的对照。环绕着耶稣出生之时的死亡与苦难的回响，也同样体现在智者们带来的乳香和没药之中。你知道我对希律王怎么看吗？我觉得希律王名誉太差了，因为事实上，如果你看看希律王的时代，希律王非常巧妙地周旋于各方势力之间，不是吗？所以他最初是和马克·安东尼（Mark Antony）站在同一阵线的，
and matthew is writing his gospel against the backdrop of the judean revolt which we're going to do uh yeah an episode about in the new year and that obviously sees the destruction of the temple which had been built by herod it sees the storming of masada which had been built by Herod. It sees the storming of Masada, which had been built by Herod. It sees the Judean revolt breakout in the great port city of Caesarea, which had been built by Herod. Basically, Herod builds everything. He's a massive man for the Grand Projet. And the issues that kind of explode in the Judean revolt, a lot of them can be traced back to the figure of Herod. And Herod has been described as one of the few historical figures who's equally loathed by Jews and Christians. But he's not, Herod is not originally Jewish himself, is he?
然后是克娄巴特拉（Cleopatra），接着他又倒戈投向了屋大维（Octavian）。好吧，屋大维召见他并说道：“嗯，你知道吗，你怎么说？你为什么一直在支持马克·安东尼？”而希律王回答说：“嗯，我曾经是马克·安东尼的好朋友，现在我是你的好朋友。”屋大维说：“好吧，很有道理。”这非常像《继承之战》（Succession）。非常像《继承之战》。他就是中东政坛上的汤姆·沃姆斯甘斯（Tom Wamsgams）。他有点像个暴发户，但他智胜了所有人。
He's Nabataean Arab, is that right? Well, he claims to be Jewish. He converts, doesn't he, to Judaism? He's not from a Jewish family. But the Judean Jewish identity is a much more fluid, he converts doesn't he to judaism he's not from a jewish family but but the judean jewish identity is a much more fluid much more complicated thing than it subsequently becomes right so he's a kind of ambivalent figure and obviously he's held up by the gospel writer as a contrast to christ who will never be a king in the conventional sense, who will go to the cross.
比克娄巴特拉活得长，比安东尼活得长。我认为他必须表现得残酷才能成功。但他有着非常悲惨的结局，对吧，希律王？他不是被虫子吃掉的吗诸如此类的？那是他的儿子亚基帕王（Herod Agrippa），不过是的，他死得很惨。有什么……怎么说来着？我刚刚读到过。他死于一种叫做“希律王的诅咒”或希律王的……
And that is the contrast. And the echoes of the death and suffering that surround his birth is also there in the frankincense and the myrrh that the wise men bring. Do you know what I'm going to say about Herod? I think Herod's got a very bad press, because actually, if you look at Herod's times, Herod moves horses very skillfully,'t he so he's originally he's originally in with Mark Antony
抓挠自己的皮肤致死。是的，“希律王的恶疾”。他死于一场疾病。我的意思是，能有一种病以你的名字命名，也算是一项相当了不起的成就了。所以……这不太好。不过，这后来成了教会的一个盛大节日……无辜婴儿被视为第一批基督教殉道者。甚至排在圣史蒂芬（Saint Stephen）之前，圣史蒂芬的殉道纪念日是节礼日（Boxing Day），即12月26日。它还启发了14世纪著名的《考文垂颂歌》（Coventry Carol）：啦，啦，啦，啦，你这小小婴孩……
and then Cleopatra and then he switches to Octavian well Octavian summons him and says well you know what do you say why have you been backing Mark Antony and he says well I was a good friend to Mark Antony and now I was a good friend to to you. And Octavian says, yeah, fair enough. It's very succession. Very succession. He's the Tom Wamsgams of Middle Eastern politics. He's a bit of a parvenu, but he outsmarts the people.
不，我唱不出来。刚才那段太精彩了，汤姆。这只是冰山一角。也许如果你加入“历史的余烬俱乐部”（The Rest Is History Club），现在加入还来得及，你就能听到汤姆完整地唱出这首歌：希律王在狂怒中发号施令，然而就在这一天，
Outlives Cleopatra, outlives Antony. And I think that he has to be brutal to be successful. But he has this very unfortunate end, doesn't he, Herod? Isn't he eaten by worms or something like that? That's his son, Herod Agrippa, but yes, he dies horribly as well. There's some, what's it, I was just reading up on it. He dies, a thing called Herod's Curse or Herod's...
他的威猛卫士在众目睽睽之下，将所有幼童残忍杀害。老实说，你只要一听就会知道这首歌。而且，令人动容的是，在1940年考文垂大教堂（Coventry Cathedral）那冒烟的废墟中，人们正是在幼童洗礼日这一天唱起这首歌的。真令人感动。
Scratching his skin off. Yeah, Herod's Evil. He dies of an illness. I mean, having an illness named after you it's quite an achievement yeah so uh not good um but this this becomes uh for for the church it becomes one of the great festivals um the the innocents are accounted the first christian martyrs so even ahead of saint stephen whose martyrdom is on boxinging Day 26th of December. And it inspires the famous Coventry carol in the 14th century. La, la, la, la, thou little tiny child.
确实很感人，不是吗？是的。我知道你是考文垂大教堂的超级粉丝，对吧？是的，太棒了。考文垂大教堂所在的城市。真令人感动。确实很感人，不是吗？是的。我知道你是考文垂大教堂的超级粉丝，对吧？是的，太棒了。考文垂这座城市，总体而言。太棒了。是的。我今年第一次去参观了重建后的教堂。
No, I can't do it. That was brilliant, Tom. That was just a taste. Maybe if you join the Restless History Club, it's not too late to join the Restless History Club, but you'll be able to hear Tom singing the whole thing. Herod the King, in his raging charge, yet he hath this day,
它是最伟大的现代英国建筑。哇。了不起的地方。了不起的地方。不过，多米尼克，这也为我们接下来的一集做好了铺垫。我们将要谈论加缪（Camus），阿尔贝·加缪（Albert Camus）。是的。他写了《坠落》（La Chute）。
his men of might in his own sight, all young children to slay. Honestly, you'll know it if you hear it. And you know, very movingly, that was sung on Childermass, so this day in 1940, in the smoking ruins of Coventry Cathedral. That is moving.
是的。在这部作品中，基督允许自己被钉死在十字架上，出于一种负罪感——因为他觉得自己没有成为那些无辜婴儿中的一员。这可一点都不像圣诞节该有的主题，汤姆。这极其具有圣诞气氛，汤姆。这极其具有圣诞气氛。这更像是复活节的主题吧，我指基督的受难，
It is moving, isn't it? Yeah. I know you're a big fan of Coventry Cathedral, aren't you? Yes, I'm wonderful. The city of Coventry Cathedral. That is moving. It is moving, isn't it? Yeah. I know you're a big fan of Coventry Cathedral, aren't you? Yes, I'm wonderful. The city of Coventry, generally. Wonderful. Yeah. I visited the rebuilt cathedral the first time this year.
不是吗？他这样做是因为圣诞节发生的事情。我知道，但我的意思是，我们不想总是谈论负罪感，我的意思是……
It's the greatest modern British building. Wow. Amazing place. Amazing place. But also, Dominic, this sets up a future episode we're going to have. We're going to talk about Camus, Albert Camus. Yeah. And he wrote La Chute, The Fall.
那才是负罪感、受害者情结，那是学术历史的素材，我们不搞那种东西，汤姆。那是圣诞节的素材。
Yeah. In which Christ allows himself to be crucified out of the guilt that he feels at not having been one of the innocents. That's not very Christmassy, Tom. It's incredibly Christmassy Tom it's incredibly Christmassy that's more Easter-y I think Christ's crucifixion
好吧，听着，我为下半场准备了一个精彩绝伦的周年纪念事件。所以，如果你因为“屠杀无辜婴儿”而情绪低落，那就振作起来吧，因为中场休息过后，我们要讲的是泰桥灾难（Tay Bridge disaster）以及历史最伟大的诗歌。
isn't it he's doing it because of something that happened at Christmas I know but I mean we don't want to be talking about guilt and I mean
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、精彩评论以及八卦猛料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
that's what guilt, victimhood that's the stuff of academic history we don't do that kind of thing Tom it's the stuff of Christmas
你好，欢迎回到这个圣诞12日特别节目。我们正在讨论12月28日发生的事件。我们已经讲过了幼童洗礼日和屠杀无辜婴儿事件。现在我们要迎来更多的死亡与毁灭。但我们还有诗歌。多米尼克，我们在这个播客里非常热爱诗歌。我们在节目中读过很多诗歌。不过我认为……你永远也找不到比这首更好的诗了。
okay well listen I have a brilliant I have a brilliant, I have a brilliant anniversary for the second half. So if you're feeling a bit low thinking about the Massacre of the Innocents, cheer up, because coming after the break is the Tay Bridge disaster and the greatest poem in history.
现在，我要为这首诗做些铺垫。我要为这首诗做铺垫，因为我不想直接切入诗歌本身。我先从死亡讲起。苏格兰有一座桥叫做泰铁路桥（Tay Rail Bridge），建于1878年6月，它横跨泰湾（Firth of Tay）通往邓迪（Dundee）。这是维多利亚时代工程学的黄金时期，充满了各种工程和建筑奇迹，而这座桥就是其中之一。这座桥长约两英里，这座铁路桥可以说是现代性和进步等的象征。它的建筑师是一个名叫
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
托马斯·伯奇（Thomas Bouch）或布什（Bouch），我觉得应该叫伯奇。现在，谈到建筑工程，这你可不陌生——我们在上半场讨论过希律王的宏大工程，这是一个严重超支的维多利亚时代宏大工程，正如宏大工程往往会做的那样。所以它就像是英国的HS2高铁项目。它就是HS2。因此在建设过程中削减了成本。而建筑师伯奇先生完全没有为强风做任何防范。
Hello, welcome back to this special 12 Days of Christmas episode. We are talking the events of the 28th of December. We've already done Childermass, the Massacre of the Innocents. And now we've got more death than destruction. But we've also got poetry. Dominic, we love a poem on this podcast. We've read a lot of poetry on it. But I think... You'll never get a better poem than this one.
哦，不。对于一座苏格兰铁路桥来说，这真是极其愚蠢。让我们把时间快进大约18个月，来到它建成之后。现在是1879年12月28日的傍晚。所以你可以想象当时的场景：漆黑的夜晚，狂风呼啸，大雨倾盆，是非常典型的苏格兰冬日天气。爱丁堡快车（Edinburgh Express）正从布伦蒂兰（Burnt Island）驶来。刚过7点钟，它驶向泰铁路桥，开上了桥。
Now, I'm going to build up to the poem. I'm going to build up to the poem because I don't want to go in on the poem. I'll go in on the death. So there is a bridge in Scotland called the Tay Rail Bridge and this is built in June 1878 and it goes across the Firth of Tay to Dundee. So it's a great age of engineering, of kind of engineering and architectural marvels in Victorian Britain and this is one of them. It runs for about two miles this bridge this rail bridge it's kind of symbol of modernity and a progress and so on uh the architect is a man
晚上7点13分，它得到了继续前行的信号，得以继续它的行程。列车有五节车厢，还挂着一节行李车，当它开到桥中央时，汤姆，它已经开到了一半，突然天空中闪过一道耀眼的强光，照亮了整个夜空，随后便是一片漆黑。那道闪光是什么？我不知道，我想那道闪光可能就是闪电吧。是的，很可能是暴风雨中的闪电。
called thomas bouch or bouch i think bouch and um now the the building work this is not unfamiliar with you're talking about grand projet in the first half herod's grand projet this is a victorian grand projet that has gone massively over budget, as Grands Projets tend to. So it's kind of HS2. It is HS2. So costs have been cut during the building. And the architect, Mr. Bouch, has made absolutely no allowance whatsoever for high winds.
但也可能是出了什么故障，我不知道，可能是火花，谁知道呢。火车并没有爆炸，但基本上是桥梁
Oh, no. Which is very foolish with a Scottish rail bridge. So let's fast forward by 18 months or so from when it was built. And we are on the evening of the 28th of December, 1879. So you can picture the scene, kind of dark night, the winds howling, the rain lashing down, very Scottish kind of winter weather. The Edinburgh Express is travelling from Burnt Island. And just after 7 o'clock, it heads towards the Tay Rail Bridge, goes onto the bridge.
连同火车一起坍塌了。就在转瞬之间，桥梁、钢架、火车以及所有的人，
At 7.13 p.m., it's given the signal to go ahead, to kind of continue its journey. And it has five carriages and it has a luggage van and it's halfway across the bridge tom it's halfway there and suddenly there was this great flash of light that illuminates the sky and then total darkness what was the flash uh i don't know i think the flash i probably was lightning yeah probably it was the middle of the storm lightning
都坠入泰河，坠入泰湾，所有人都遇难了。现在，没有人能确定火车上到底有多少人。大约75人，包括工作人员在内。没有一个人幸存。现在，对于伯奇先生来说，最可怕的是，他已经不再是伯奇先生了，他被封为了爵士（Sir Thomas）。你敢信，他因为这座桥而被册封为爵士？
but also maybe something going wrong I don't know sparks or who knows the train doesn't blow up but basically the bridge
“造桥爵士”。“苏格兰造桥爵士”。不到一年后，他就因震惊和精神痛苦而离世了。真让人难以置信。是的。所以这是一个非常悲伤的故事，所有这些人都在这座桥上丧生。不过，人们记住这件事并不是因为这个，因为这个故事——这个非常悲伤的时刻——引起了一个人的注意，他就是
collapses with the train on it so within moments the bridge the girders the train all the people
威廉·麦哥纳高尔（William McGonagall）——也就是《哈利·波特》中麦格教授（Professor McGonagall）名字的灵感来源——他以“有史以来最糟糕的诗人”而闻名。所以威廉·麦哥纳高尔是个挺有趣的人。他的家庭可能是爱尔兰人，曾在维多利亚时代的英国到处迁徙以寻找工作。威廉曾经是一名手织工，所以他没受过什么教育。但他热爱莎士比亚，对吧？他确实热爱莎士比亚。你有什么关于他扮演麦克白的好笑故事要告诉我们吗？我有。
down into the tay into the Firth of Tay and everybody dies murderers, the train, all the people, down into the Tay, into the Firth of Tay, and everybody dies. Now, no one's quite sure exactly how many people are on the train. Probably about 75 people, including the staff. There are no survivors at all. Now, the terrible thing for Mr. Bouch, he's no longer Mr. Bouch, he's Sir Thomas. He's been knighted for the bridge, would you believe?
你怎么知道的？你显然也在博德利图书馆（Bodleian Library）做过和我一样的研究。我其实是为了我们的《麦克白》那一集查过这个资料，但后来忘了提了。所以当威廉·麦哥纳高尔在织布机旁工作时，据说他会——可以说是“娱乐”，但我看大概是“烦扰”他的同事们——通过背诵莎士比亚的片段，因为他是一个伟大的自学成才者。
Sir Sister Bridge Building. Sir Sister Scottish Bridge Building. And less than a year later, he dies of shock and distress of mind. That's in credit. Yeah. So it's a very sad story, all these people killed on this bridge. Now, that's not really why people remember this, because this story, this very sad moment moment comes to the attention of a man called
这正是你和同事一起工作时最希望遇到的，对吧？当然。大声背诵莎士比亚的独白。是的，完全如此。所以有一次，其他工人们出资贿赂了一位当地的剧院老板，让他得以在《麦克白》的一场制作中出演主角。这可能是他们试图摆脱他的某种方式，我不知道。
william mcgonigal the inspiration for harry potter's professor mcgonigal in the name famous as the worst poet in recorded history so william mcgonigal is a kind of interesting man he his family's probably irish and they've been moving around in Victorian Britain to find work. And William was a handloom weaver, so he's got no education. But he loved Shakespeare, didn't he? He did love Shakespeare. Do you have an amusing story to tell us about him playing Macbeth? I do.
这倒真有可能。麦哥纳高尔心里认定，扮演麦克导（Macduff）的那家伙嫉妒他。为了报复，他在最后一幕中坚决拒绝死去。所以扮演麦克导的家伙正试图杀死他，
How do you know? You've obviously been doing the same research as me in the Bodleian Library. I actually looked this up for our I'm at Beth episode, and I forgot to mention it. So when he was working at his loom, William McGonagall would, it says entertain, but I think probably annoy his fellow workers by reciting bits of Shakespeare, because he's a great autodidact.
而他就是死不肯倒下。哦，是的。我认为这正是一个伟大的文学工匠和一个伟大的表演者的标志。到了1877年，当时麦哥纳高尔大概50岁左右，
That's what you want, isn't it, with a fellow worker? Of course. To point Shakespeare's soliloquies. Yeah, exactly. So at one point, the other workers pay a local theatre owner to allow him to appear in the title role in a production of Macbeth. This may be their way of trying to get rid of him, I don't know.
他经历了一次近乎宗教般的皈依。灵感降临在他身上了，对吧？确实如此。你想让我读读他是怎么说的吗？好吧。他说：“我似乎觉得，有一种奇怪的感觉悄然向我袭来，
That could be you. McGonagall gets it into his head that the guy who's playing Macduff is jealous of him. And to get his revenge, he refuses to die in the final act. So this guyff is jealous of him. And to get his revenge, he refuses to die in the final act. So this guy's trying to kill him. And he just won't die.
我就那样持续了大约五分钟。正如拜伦勋爵所说，一团火焰点燃了我的整个身躯，伴随着一种强烈的想要写诗的渴望。我感到如此快乐，如此快乐，以至于我忍不住想要跳舞。然后我开始在房间里来回踱步，试图摆脱所有想要写诗的念头。我感到如此快乐，如此快乐，以至于我忍不住想要跳舞。然后我开始在房间里来回踱步，试图摆脱所有想要写诗的念头。”
Oh, yes. So that's the sign of a great literary craftsman, I think, and a great showman. And in 1877, when McGonagall is probably about 50,
“但我越是试图摆脱，这种感觉就越强烈。它是如此强烈，以至于我仿佛觉得右手握着一支笔，耳边有一个声音在大喊：‘写！写！’。我的意思是，汤姆，你刚开始写历史的时候也有这种感觉吗？嗯，有时候我会在半夜醒来，琢磨着这些词句到底还会不会涌现。好吧，威廉·麦哥纳高尔可没有被这个问题困扰。不，他没有。他简直无法做更好的广告了。所以一年后，他从邓迪出发——这故事太搞笑了。
he has this almost religious conversion. The news comes on him, doesn't it? It does. Do you want me to read you what he says? Yeah. He says, I seem to feel, as it were, a strange kind of feeling stealing over me,
他从邓迪步行走到巴尔莫勒尔（Balmoral）。那大约有60英里远。他翻山越岭地走过去。去向女王毛遂自荐，对吧？顶着猛烈的雷暴。去向女王毛遂自荐。当他到达巴尔莫勒尔时，他向卫兵自报家门。他说：“我是女王的御用诗人。”
and I remained so for about five minutes. A flame, as Lord Byron has said, kindled up my entire frame, along with a strong desire to write poetry. And I felt so happy, so happy, that I was inclined to dance. Then I began to pace backwards and forwards in the room, trying to shake off all thought of write poetry. And I felt so happy, so happy that I was inclined to dance. Then I began to pace backwards and forwards in the room, trying to shake off all thought of writing poetry.
卫兵对他说：“你才不是女王的御用诗人。丁尼生（Tennyson）才是女王的御用诗人。”于是麦哥纳高尔勃然大怒。而且他……原因是他曾写信给女王，表达自己想成为她的御用诗人的愿望。并且他已经开始写诗了。
But the more I tried, the more strong the sensation became. It was so strong, I imagined a pen was in my right hand and a voice crying, write, write. I mean, Tom, did you have this when you first came to you to write history? Well, sometimes I wake up in the middle of the night wondering whether the words will ever come. Well, that problem did not afflict William McGonagall. No, it did not. He could never have advertised a better help. So a year later, he walks from Dundee. It's such a funny story.
而王室里的某个随从给他回了一封格式化的信，上面写着：“女王非常感谢您的来信，并将以兴趣关注您的职业生涯。”他当时想：“太棒了，我在路上了。”所以他并没有因此气馁。因此，在巴尔莫勒尔事件发生两年后，他决定写一首关于泰桥灾难的诗。这就是那首被人们公认为他的巅峰之作的诗——这首有史以来最糟糕的诗，因为他是个糟糕透顶的诗人。
He walks from Dundee to Balmoral. So that's about 60 miles. He walks over through the mountains. To offer his services to the Queen, right? Through a violent thunderstorm. To offer his services. And when he arrives at Balmoral, he announces himself to the guards. He says, I am the Queen's poet.
这首诗很长。所以我只读开头和结尾。这首诗的名字叫《泰桥灾难，1880年》（The Tay Bridge Disaster, 1880）。它是这样开头的：“美丽的银色泰河铁路桥啊，唉，我很遗憾地告诉大家，在1879年的最后一个安息日，有90条生命被夺走了，这将被人们长久地铭记。哦，命运多舛的银色泰河桥啊，我现在必须结束我的诗篇，无所畏惧、毫无惊慌地向全世界宣告，你们的中央钢架本不该坍塌，至少许多明智的
And the guards say to him, you're not the Queen's poet. Tennyson is the Queen's poet. So McGonagall is outraged. And he's... The reason is because he had written to the Queen to tell her that he wanted to become her poet. And he'd taken up poetry.
人们都这样说，如果它们在两侧有扶壁支撑的话……至少许多明智的人承认，因为我们把房子建造得越坚固，我们被夺去生命的几率就越小。”这太棒了！但只要你一听到“扶壁”（buttresses），你就知道他接下来要跟什么押韵了——他押的是“承认”（confesses）。你觉得这是一个好韵脚吗？“扶壁”和“承认”。我觉得这不是个好韵脚，不。是的，嗯，我觉得对我来说，汤姆，这里的问题在于那句“这将被人们长久地铭记”。是的。我觉得这给第一段写了一个相当可悲的结尾。
And some flunky in the royal household had sent back a form letter saying, The Queen is very grateful for your communication. And will follow your career with interest. He was like, great, I'm on my way. So he's not deterred by this. And so two years after this incident at Balmoral, he decides he's going to write about the Tay Bridge disaster. And this is the poem that I think people agree is his masterpiece, the single worst poem, because he's a terrible, terrible poet.
你是在认真地进行文学批评吗？是的，对威廉·麦哥纳高尔的诗歌进行批评。好吧，他写散文也很有一套。是吗？“我这本自传的亲爱的读者们，这本书的作者正是我本人。”不过，多米尼克，你知道吗，你读过他是如何在马戏团打工赚钱的吗？我其实不知道。你想跟我讲讲吗？我的意思是，他可没有被邀请去参加文学节。他没有吗？
So it's very long. So I'm just going to read the beginning and the end. So it's called The Tay Bridge Disaster, 1880. Here's how it begins. Beautiful railway bridge of the silvery tay. Alas, I am very sorry to say that 90 lives have been taken away on the last Sabbath day of 1879, which will be remembered for a very long time. Oh, ill-fated bridge of the silvery tay. I now must conclude my lay by telling the world fearlessly without the least dismay that your central girders would not have given way at least many sensible
没有，他没有。所以他沦落到在马戏团打工，在马戏团里朗诵他的诗歌。而观众被邀请用鸡蛋、面粉和其他食物砸他。他们是被邀请的。所以他们被提前告知要带这些东西来。是的。这就像上播客一样。是的。
men do say had they been supported on each side by buttresses at least many sensible men confesses for the stronger we our houses do build the less chance we have of being killed that's great but the moment you hear buttresses i think you're a dog to know what he's going to rhyme with that confesses do you think that's a good rhyme buttresses confesses i don't think that's a great rhyme no yeah well i think i think that to me tom the the problem there is which will be remembered for a very long time. Yeah. I think that's quite a pathetic end to that first verse.
我希望我们做《历史的余烬》时不会遇到这种事。我知道。太可怕了。人们用鸡蛋砸我们。那可太让人沮丧了。但他确实算是一个悲剧人物。绝对是个悲剧人物。你知道的，
Are you seriously engaging in practical criticism? Yeah, of William McGowan Gorse poetry. Well, he was very good at prose as well. Was he? My dear readers of this autobiography, which I am the author of. But Dominic, do you know, did you read about how he tried to make money working in a circus? I didn't actually. Would you like to tell me about that? I mean, he wasn't invited to the literary festivals. He wasn't?
一种非常典型的人物，因为他完全没有意识到自己的名声如何。是的。是的。是的。而且我认为，因为那个泰桥……
No, he wasn't. So he was reduced to working in a circus at which he would read his poetry. And the audience was invited to pelt him with eggs, flour and other comestibles. They were invited. So they were told to bring them beforehand. Yeah. It's like being on a podcast. Yeah.
泰桥这首诗之所以被人铭记，是因为题材的悲剧性与处理方式的荒谬性之间构成了巨大的不协调，是的……那种绝对的麻木不仁，是的。那种绝对的麻木不仁。总之，这就结束了……关于威廉·麦哥纳高尔或泰铁路桥，我已经没什么可说的了。好吧，你算是为他伸张正义了。很好，我没有用苏格兰口音来读。你刚才其实……有那么一点暗示。有一点点幽微的暗示。带有苏格兰口音的幽微暗示。
I hope that doesn't happen to us when we do like the rest is history. I know. Terrible. People pelt us with eggs. That'd be very depressing. But it can be the kind of tragic figure. Definitely a tragic figure. You know,
让全世界一窥你的麦克白可能会是什么德行。没错。更不用说我的帕丁顿熊了。好吧，所以我绝对
a very sort of, cause he's not that classic thing of somebody who's completely unaware of his reputation. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And I think cause that, the tape that the,
不会在下一集里模仿口音，否则节目就要被取消了。我们下一集要讲什么来着？提醒我一下。好吧，我们要讲我的另一场戏剧表演，因为你选择了托马斯·贝克特（Thomas Beckett），
the, the thing with the, the reason the Tay Bridge poem is remembered is cause the incongruity of the tragedy of the subject and the ridiculousness of the handling yeah um the absolute insensitivity yeah the absolute insensitivity anyway that concludes um that i've got nothing left to say about william mcgonagall or the tape tape rail bridge well i think you've done it justice good i didn't do it a scottish accent um you kind of there was a hint there was a tiny. There was a ghostly hint. A ghostly hint of a Scottish accent.
难道你没选托马斯·贝克特吗？而我选的是伤膝河大屠杀（Massacre at Wounded Knee），所以我觉得我还是别模仿任何口音了。好吧，那我们明天见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需获取独家加更节目、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistory.com 注册。
Giving the world a glimpse of what your Macbeth might have been. That's right. Not to say my Paddington. Right. So, I'm definitely not
网址是 restishistory.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
going to do an accent to the next episode because it will be cancelled. What are we doing for the next episode? Remind me. Well, we're doing another of my theatrical performances because you're doing Thomas Beckett
下一集要用口音来做，因为这一集要被取消了。我们下一集要做什么？提醒我一下。哦对，我们要进行我的另一场戏剧表演，因为你要演托马斯·贝克特
haven't you chosen to do Thomas Beckett and I'm doing the Massacre at Wounded Knee so I don't think I should do any voices alright we'll see you tomorrow, bye bye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
你不是选了演托马斯·贝克特吗，而我要讲伤膝河大屠杀，所以我觉得我不应该模仿什么声音。好吧，那我们明天见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要收听独家节目、提前畅听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。